Husband and he's like sitting
there sipping into what's going on,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 13th,
2017 what's going on out? Why? Yeah.
Oh y'all. How are you doing over there?
Why is it uh,
why is Friday the 13th on lucky Monday
the 13th all that's just fucking fuck.
You know, it was a put, so
you came up with that one.
You think Monday the 13th fuck you're
unlucky 13 and it's Monday and I got five
fucking days in front of me. I have
to work Friday 13 who gives a shit?
You stub your toe a couple of times and
next thing you know you're at the TGI
Friday's right? You're down there
eyeball and one of the lady,
yeah, we'd come up to her. You
tell her you like her stripe shirt.
Start bitching about the horrible day
you had, you know, and she's a woman,
so she'll listen to it.
She'll kick into that motherly instinct
unless she already has kids and then she
doesn't have time for it, you know? Then
she looks and just says, listen mate,
sucking your Dick. All right,
so just get the fuck out of here and
then you move on to something yoga.
So then I'll goes, why? What is
so fucking unlucky? You know what?
I didn't even know I was going
to. I got to look this up now,
why is Friday the 13th unlucky. Hang
on a stomach. Hit pause for a second.
Alright, before I can, I just looked
it up. I didn't read any. I just got,
I just got to the Google thing where they
get whatever it is on the first page.
All right. Who's kid knew with the
Internet? Whatever the fact is,
the fact is whatever you look up within
the first two fucking clicks on the
first page becomes the
truth. That's it. Okay,
so that's what the fuck I'm looking at.
You know if the right answer
to any question is fucking
beyond what you have to
scroll down on the first page of any
subject on a of the Internet, it's,
it's over. No one's ever going
to know the truth because it who?
Who the fuck ever goes to page 14
okay.
Not even journalists do that. They
don't give a shit. I'm all right.
I'm going to say it
either has to do with, uh,
it's gotta be religious. It's gotta
be religious. Jesus did something.
He always had bad Friday. Sydney.
No, he had a good Friday. Good.
Today's Good Friday. What
happened on Good Friday? Did He,
the little rock roll
back. He came walking up,
you know,
like one of those fucking movies where
they thought they killed the guy and he
didn't. And then he comes back. Step,
not like Tom Sawyer fucking creep
hanging out at his own funeral.
I was done with that kid
once he did that shows like,
this kid's a fucking
Weirdo. I'm all right. Fine.
13th why is it unlucky and other facts
about the worst day in the calendar?
In the calendar, not on the calendar.
We're in it. We're not in it.
We're not on it. Right? Find it.
13th considered by many is one of the
unluckiest days of the year is almost here
again. This is from January, 2017. Oh.
Oh Shit. January 13th well fuck. Nothing
happened to us if he's still alive. Um,
if you're worried about
what's in storable, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, what the fuck in
2007 here's some of the fun facts.
When is the next Friday? The
13th now, why stupid? All right.
Biblical orange origins. All right.
Course. It always goes back to the Bible.
Oh Jesus. Dad's mad. Dad's coming home.
He's not in a good fucking mood.
He had a bad week, you know?
Of course it's the kids fault. Stupid con.
He tried to build everything
in six fucking days.
Typical do it yourself job.
Why didn't you farm it out to someone
who knew what the fuck they were doing?
Built the thing up to code.
You Dope fucking sticking a steel beam
in the middle of a fucking wood wall.
Yeah. Everything above it is supported
better. What about below it? That,
what about below it? The fuck
did this music come from?
All right, let's read with this
music on in the background.
[inaudible]
the superstition about
this day is not to have,
I can't do this to have come about.
All right. That's enough of that.
During the Middle Ages in
many have biblical origins,
some historians have claimed it was the
day on which he bit the apple from the
tree of knowledge. Jesus Christ.
Hmm.
Holy. That just scared the shit out of
me. Nia, the lovely Nia. Everybody. Oh,
with my beautiful daughter.
Two lovely ladies.
What's going on? Uh, I thought
you were done. Sorry. No,
I was watching the videos that people
sent me this week. What's going on?
Or you're going to drop her off? No,
I can't do the podcast the way I talk.
That's why I was in here with the door
closed. It's a pocket door, by the way.
If you wonder why you're squeak.
Like we live in a haunted house. No,
I just found another,
I just saw another place that I wanted
to show you that maybe you wanted to
order from. Yeah, just order me
something remotely healthy. Okay.
Something to stave off the calories I
consume in alcohol. Okay. What'd you like?
Some sort of like a, a bowl, like with
rice and Tofu and that sort of thing.
I hate Tofu. It's gotta be a real dead
animal that have vegetables. Okay,
so you want,
you want meat so I shouldn't order
from a vegan place then I like,
I'm Vegan. As long as
there's none of that Tofu,
I don't understand what that stuff is.
That's like the type of shit that
they seal capsule with. So, Tofu. Yes.
So liquid doesn't be good. It's not
good for you. Tofu is not good for,
you know, are you sure you're
thinking of Tofu or are you,
what is Tofu doesn't come from a tree,
does it? There's no Tofu. Food. Trees.
I thought TOEFL was made from soybeans.
Yeah, but isn't soy bad for you?
Not always. I have no, wait,
let me get your phone for you.
I don't know if you're going
to order from a Vegan place.
Just get me vegetables, shit that
I, I, you know, I know what it is.
I know what it is. I
don't know what Tofu is.
It's like fucking algae or
something. Okay. All right. Shuffles.
Nia. Do you know why Friday the 13th
is unlucky. Why? I don't know either.
I've been reading about it
here. The new and then uh,
they try to say that Eve
fucking maybe bit the apple. Oh,
they went paradise. There was no calendar.
What do they have to worry about?
Snow bills. They didn't have to
go to work as a woman. You know,
what are they doing in
fucking eat off shit. Monday.
Same Shit ever day. It's fucking paradise.
No salad though.
I also don't understand
why if it was paradise,
why they had a fucking snake in
there trying to fuck everything up.
What was the devil?
Yeah, but that's on God.
The God and the devil
are two separate. Yeah.
They're not too safe. God
made everything else I made.
He also made the contact
ball constantly. Not,
I don't think. Oh no, but the
devil was an angel that got Casco.
So the devil was
basically a bad hire. Yes.
That came back and tried to take his
company down. All right. Yeah. Okay.
Let me finish reading this.
Okay. In the New Testament, um,
I love how they blame the woman. Like,
that's why everything's all fucked up.
I mean, without a doubt,
if you told abroad did not go over
there and eat the fucking apple,
she's going to be intrigued.
Yeah.
You know, like a guy wouldn't, whatever
you day. That's still classic thing.
Like at substitute teaching,
whatever you do, don't laugh.
Next person who lapse gets
detention. That's it. You're done.
You fucking squeeze in your nose
doing that fucking little kid laugh.
That's it, nick. See, no, you
missing a week of research, a recess.
That's why you got all
these fat fucking kids.
The regular teacher takes the day off.
The substitute teacher creates
the tension though. The,
the one skinny kid starts
laughing and then he's done.
He's eaten that fucking food down the
cafeteria that's got all the preservatives
in it. Do you know if you
fucking kill somebody in the end?
Nobody figures it out. You're not
in the clear for a good 40 years.
That's how let the digging people up
from 12 years ago and then that's like,
they took a fucking nap. Hey,
I'll tell you, these people,
they're full of preservatives, you
know? All right. And the New Testament,
there were 13 people present for
Jesus. Jesus, his last supper
on Monday. Thursday.
Yeah.
Monty m. M. A. U. N. D. Y. Is that
some other fucking day of the week?
They used to have,
what do you mean the new testament
that wasn't in the Old Testament. Oh,
wait a minute.
We fucked up that there was 12
this 13 the day before crisis.
Crucifixion on Good
Friday. Oh, Good Friday.
See when Audi had a couple of
bears, he had a good fucking time.
And the next thing you know, you've got
the old right there, Fred. All right,
more bad luck on Friday, October 13th,
1307 Phillip, the fourth of France.
Shouldn't be a Felipe like cat, um,
arrested hundreds of
of the knights Templar
and isn't, well, what the forward, what
did they do then is novel Davinci Code.
Dan Brown cites the 14th century
execution. Oh, who gives a fuck?
You know what I mean? You know something,
it's, it's just all bullshit. That's
what it is. You always knew it was,
I'm trying to think of any
bad's ever happened on the 13th,
but I pay on Fadiman.
You get bad luck today.
Fucking old ladies keeping that shit
going. That's what it is. Oh, by the way,
I'm really good friend of mine and one
of the fucking best comedians I've ever
seen. Nick Depalo the Great Nick Depalo.
He has a new standup special,
a new one hour standup special
that's debuting a this Thursday, um,
February 16th at eight,
8:00 PM on CSO TV called inflammatory. Um,
I don't get to watch him as much
since I'm out here and, but he,
he is somebody,
last time I worked with them was
it comics come home once again?
Legendary set and um, that's it.
He's just one of those fucking
guys. He's just, he's the guy. Um,
he's the shit and he's got a new
special on CSO. Check it out. Thursday,
Friday after Thursday, February 16th
at 8:00 PM, it's called inflammatory.
And he also used to host
a show with, uh, um,
rd Lang and now he's
doing his own podcast, uh,
to subscribe to his podcast.
You can go to connect pal.
C O n n e c t pal.com/nick.
Um, all right, there we
go. So do you know what?
You know what the Fuck I did today?
You know what my dumb ass did?
Today's I getting on the elliptical,
which was a good thing. All right.
I took my life insurance fucking test.
This guy had a problem hitting my vein.
He goes, you're going to bruise a little
bit. You should see me. I look like a,
okay.
I don't look like I've been doing smack.
I just look like somebody just
pinched my fucking inside of my elbow.
Really fucking hard. Um,
anyway, so I did all that. Ugh.
What a shit show that was fucking guys
sitting there going did drink it all
right. And like, wait, he's
got his back to my bar,
which I told you his murderer's row,
the bottles I have there. I told you I,
right now I put it up against
the 27 Yankees, the 96 balls.
Let's go some underrated
teams. The 83 76 hours.
Some are lost in history about how
fucking great they were. Right.
The 86 Celtics, the 85 Lakers,
the fucking in 2060 New England patriots,
the 98 Yankees, that was a great team
for the fucking free agent there waiting.
I mean, speaking of which, now that
the red sox are doing that this year,
that's a good year to get the package.
No matter what you're going
to be entertained. You,
they get to watch like a fucking $900
million team, shit the bed or just,
you know, there is no Santa Clause.
We're buying one or the other.
Either way it's going to be
dramatic. Um, so anyways, I got uh,
such a funny question. I'm like,
drinks, tea. I don't fucking know.
Okay.
Do I have a pocket protector? I don't
count them. I like, you know, they,
they always, you know what's funny,
they fucking say having a glass of wine
with your meal is actually good for you.
You know what I mean? So I mean,
I don't, I don't understand that.
Okay.
The smoke. Yeah. Yellow a little bit.
It's fucking lying your ass off. Um,
okay.
Oh, Jesus. I W can you imagine
if he, if can't imagine anybody,
even the fucking people who work there,
if you answered any of those questions,
fucking honestly. You know
what I mean? Alright. Uh,
Bruins and I probably shouldn't be
talking about this. Who gives a shit?
There's a comedy podcast. These
are all jokes. Everybody. Um,
this is what I did today. My fucking
dumb ass did today. So, you know,
I'm gonna be the person presenter
at the writers guild. No, the,
the, yeah, the writer's guild
awards thing, right? And,
uh, so they say it's a black
tie thing and I'm, my God, fuck,
I gotta get a fucking Tuxedo. So
I call up. By the time I call up,
it's too late to get one. So Nia,
Google sent pictures and
everybody seems like relaxed.
Like they're just wearing suits
with a black tie. So I say, fuck it.
I wear one of my suits. I pull
out a suit, I get the shirt,
we do the whole fucking thing.
I got it to go in all that.
So today I'm dressing up, you know,
I'm hanging with my daughter.
I'm putting my time in, you know,
cause I'm gonna be gone for three,
four hours and a Nia is going to be
handled by herself and I'm going to go out
and go do this, this fucking
Hollywood thing, right. And uh,
and I'm sitting there
and I know, you know,
the red carpet and everything's
between three or four. And I'm like,
can I can't, I don't know when the
fuck the car's coming to pick me up.
I'm all dressed up, ready to go, you
know, two o'clock two oh five to 10 to 15.
I'm texting people, hey, once his car
coming to get me to 25, I walk outside,
I'm looking around, I don't see anybody
just sitting there and it finally
dawns on me. I'm like, wait a minute.
And I just looked up the date of the
fucking awards show. It's next Sunday.
That hilarious. You know, the funny thing
about it is it is Nia got mad at me.
What did you write things
down? Don't give it up.
Okay.
It's not, I didn't miss it. I just was
a little early and now I know, you know,
I know that you know, I
know what I'm going to wear.
I'm actually way ahead of the
game cause I cause I fucked up.
What do you want from me?
Um, anyway, speaking of,
uh, this is something I've got to
let you guys know about. Um, the, uh,
the Patrice O'Neal comedy
benefit, the fifth annual,
but Theresa Neil comedy
event, uh, benefit, uh,
we're actually going to be
releasing some, um, some tickets,
some a high quality tickets I guess you
say some really good seats and we're
going to be doing that, uh, Monday
today. If you listen to it on Monday,
Jesus Christ with the fucking open under
the door there because it's ridiculous.
That's why. What is ridiculous, Amy,
on the podcast? Oh, am I trashing you?
Because you were saying like, I got mad
at you because you can we come here,
come here, come, come in here, come in
and come in and don't yell, don't yell.
You got the kid there. What?
It's absolutely absurd for you to
not know when things are anymore.
It's like you're a grown ass man and
you've got all dressed to go to this.
Why is it always grown ass? Why
can't you say you're grown up?
I can say whatever I want to say and I'm
choosing to say that you're a grown ass
man who can't seem to write anything
down yet because you're a strong woman to
the point where you're going to get
all dressed up and be like, well,
what am I going to wear?
There's none the other,
and then you come downstairs
five minutes later like, well,
it's next week with you.
You need to get it together.
It's not cute.
Okay.
Yeah. That's like the first thing
I've screwed up like that a long time.
I have a bunch of events in my
phone right in the calendar section
we're getting when things are,
you're always getting the dates wrong
and it's frustrating. It's just annoying.
Yeah.
All right, but how am I doing as a dad?
What does that have to do with anything
you're doing? Amazingly as all right.
We'll stop acting like I'm in some pain
shooting heroin in an alley and I'm not
acting like get shooting heroin
in an alley, but you just need,
I just don't understand why you can't
ever get your schedule straight.
You're always getting the dates wrong.
Like, oh, it's tomorrow. Not Today.
It's next week. Not this week.
Like I don't have them get it.
Yeah, I'm busy, but I don't
have an assistant. You will.
You should get an assistant. I don't
want another person to talk to.
I've been telling you to get an assistant
for like three years now because of
this very reason.
Yeah.
You want to hear all this shit I did this
week that I made totally got there on
time. No, you don't. Okay. You know why?
Because that would prove my point
if I was a baseball. What is your,
what is your point exactly? At 99% of
Shit, I get there on time. 99% well,
98 no.
When you did get mad at me, I'm not.
I did well then. What's the problem?
Why did you have to dramatically open
our squeaky pocket door to come in here
and cert yourself on the podcast?
I Dunno. All right.
Are you done? Are you kicking me
out now? Are you almost done? No,
I've just started. Oh, you just started
it. Well, people send me a note.
I'm 17 minutes in. Oh, Jesus. Oh, I
came up here to watch the grammys,
but I can't turn the TV on now. Right.
It'll go watch the grammys. Okay.
I'm going to,
is it going to be a bunch of people like
right new versus about how Trump's the
most evil thing ever.
There's some chick that showed up on
the red carpet wearing a sparkly dress.
Right.
Make America great again. And
then Trump on the back of it.
I don't know who she is, but everyone's
already like, what? Oh my God.
She's like, just for somebody
to show up at a Hollywood event like that
and addressed it says like, you know,
it's pro Trump is pretty pretty
paint by numbers shock, I guess.
So. Do you think she'll get some free
press out of that? I think she will. Yeah.
Was she wearing Madonna's
baret no, she was not.
I'm going to a protest.
What should I wear? Uh, no.
She's wearing a pro Trump approach.
Trump dress is what I'm saying. I know.
I know because that
other shit is played out.
It's acting like the sky is falling,
so now they're going to go the
other direction. Yeah, I know,
but I feel like that's not going
to be like good press for her.
You know what I mean? Hey, totes.
Any, any press is good. Press. Yeah.
Tell this dirty town works.
Yeah, I guess so. Okay.
Well you could just put
out a good album, right?
And not rely on your stupid clothes.
Yeah. If you put out a good albums,
you can keep your clothes on. You
don't have to say who you voted for.
You can just go up there and a except
your shiny thing. That's true. All right,
I'm going to take the baby. Okay.
Okay. Bye. Okay, bye. Um, anyways.
Hi everybody. I'm glad. Yes. All right,
Chloe, if you pull the door lower,
it doesn't squeak as
much. See, there you go.
See that? No. Well, you almost did it.
You could watch the
Grammy's near go ahead.
Okay.
Um, anyways, oh, by the way,
I'm going to fuck this up.
The two fucking best channels
right now in my, in my, uh,
not humble opinion. Hey, people
say in my humble opinion,
like you're a humble person. You're not,
you're injecting your fucking ideas
most likely into a conversation that you
just overheard. Or is that
just me in my opinion?
I don't know when the humble came about,
you know, hey, you know, I'm, who am I?
Who am I? Who are you? You're the
fucking guy that is, is, you know,
holding court right now with your
opinions is not that fucking humble about
this. He's shining a spotlight
on yourself. You know,
I'm actually in a good mood too.
Hang on a second. Let me meet.
Let me fucking find this stuff. Um,
there's two fucking channels out there.
Viceland is the shit. I already told
you about that. And now what's his face?
Uh, puffy. She has a new network. Puffy.
You can't pla fees network.
They said net worth revolt. It's
another great fucking channel.
Both of those channels remind me of
the early days of MTV. The early days,
the MTV was somewhere between, um,
obviously regular television and then
just basic cable fucking lunatics,
which I really miss. I remember
I used to watch this guy. Uh,
okay.
Damon ZX talks about this a long time
ago in the it, it'll be an Anthony show.
He used to pretend he was
running for office. Damon,
Zach's there. It, there it is.
This guy was a fucking superstar.
I think it was channel eight. There he is.
I love this fucking guy.
Oh, this is, this isn't gonna
translate. Well, d a m. O. N. Z. X.
N he used to do this thing where you
pretend that he was running for office,
this crazy makeup on and just
saying all this fucked up shit.
And me and Bobby Kelly were
living together when stone sober,
we would just watch that guy.
Okay.
Like late night after we did our spots,
just ordered Chinese food and would just
sit there watching the guy laughing our
asses off and fucking getting freaked out.
Um,
I dunno. But the early days of MTV was
like that and I haven't seen, you know,
network television or basic cable
be like that in a long time.
And I got to tell you
those two fucking channels,
um,
just great. A bunch of random
shit in there. Uh, original shows.
Um,
I don't know, puffy channels more
like, I just sat there watching it.
And was that guy a, what the fuck's
his name? Not Mike Jones guys.
Really killer Mike Killer. Mike. And
I guess the guy he raps with is white.
I don't know anything about, but
they fucking just filled them.
They just sat around talking about
their albums. One Guy Smoking weed,
he has like a fucking coughing
fit for like 30 seconds.
They don't even edit it out. I don't,
I was just sitting there and I'm
like two hours into this thing going,
how the fuck am I still watching this?
But it's way more interesting than
a lot of, I don't know. I like it.
Check it out if he, if he, if you
like it, you like it, whatever.
What are you going to do? Um,
anyways. All right, let's, uh,
let's talk about the world of sports
as I always do, as I eventually do,
as I always make my way back to
the old bread and circus here. Um,
Bruce Cassidy, new coach of the,
uh, Boston Bruins, former player,
came up with the Blackhawks
in like the eighties,
and unfortunately had like
three or four knee injuries.
This is all I know about
the guy. And then, um,
he paid his fucking dues
as a coach coming up.
My favorite stop that he had
on the way up, he coached for
the Jacksonville Lizard Kinks,
which, you know, I'm throwing in,
I'm throwing my vote and
that's one of the best, uh,
that's one of the best fucking names from
minor league team or the Lizard Kings.
It's a reference to the doors.
They've got a bunch of reptiles in Florida
and fucking Jim Morrison got arrested
in Florida for allegedly
taking his dick out.
Also known in some circles as you lizard.
Okay.
And who doesn't want to be a king? You
know, you've got the Sacramento Kings,
you got the La kings and he got the
Jacksonville Lizard Kings. Anyways,
he's undefeated so far, you
know, granted, you know,
we were playing our best hockey I felt
to this season when I, when he took over.
But, uh, this is a new guy, you
know, I got to a support there.
Um, what's his face? Pasa knock with
the fucking, uh, with the game where
against the Vancouver Canucks after you
made a very sketchy past in the first
period. He makes it up
fucking unbelievable. K
down the fucking left side,
slammed on the brakes, just
like I do it. Pick up hockey,
except he actually stopped rather than
continuing into the boards in hurting
himself. Um, and then fucking little,
whatever the fuck he didn't, he put it in.
It was fantastic. Oh,
it was tremendous. Um,
but I got to tell you guys about the
greatest sporting event I think I've been
to since I went to the, uh,
New England patriots first Los Angeles
Rams when we won our first super bowl
and all I can tell you about
Duke at Cameron indoor arena.
It's like
how loud the crowd was when Vinod
Terry kicked that field goal.
It was that loud, the whole fucking game.
I've never been to anything
like it. And we sat in the low,
we was sitting center court. I thought
we're going to be behind the bench.
Sorry about that. We
will send a court, um,
not on the student side across from
them and the lower area. And Dude,
I'll tell you, there's no
fucking way to get out of there.
There's no way to go to the
bathroom. There's no way to fucking,
there's nobody coming around
to concessions. You are
fucked. You are in there.
And that is it. Old School, fucking barn.
Um,
you went in, it's so small, I
guess it holds like 9,000 people,
but you felt like you were in
there with like 200 people.
And we came in and it was already a,
they were already shooting
around before the game. And uh,
we finally got to our seats.
Like you just don't think that your
seats are even going to be there because
everybody is so jammed in. And um,
we didn't sit down for
the whole fucking game.
I guess I started sitting down during
timeouts cause I'm old and I gotta tell
you I've never, I'd never seen
an atmosphere like that ever.
This beats everything. I've
been to the a NCAA a, uh,
the championship game was in the
fucking Georgia dome. So I mean,
that's a shitty place to watch your
basketball game. Even people going nuts.
It just floats up to the top
of the, the, the, the domain.
You don't even hear it.
Um, I've, I've just, I,
I don't even know why I
didn't know where to begin.
And then it was an unbelievable
gain just back and forth,
back and forth when it looked
like UNC was going to pull away,
Duke would come back.
Then it looked like Duke was going to
have the game on ice and then UNC would
come back. Somebody hit a three,
someone else would hit a
fucking three was unbelievable.
And I was very impressed with both
teams. I liked that kid on UNC number 44.
He doesn't rattle.
He doesn't fucking act like he changed
the game of basketball when he hits a
shot he gave a fuck about was winning.
He had some big three pointer and then
they immediately called timeout rather
than thumping his own chest and
acting like he's in Braveheart.
He came back to the bench
high five. But you see,
he was pissed because they just had just
let up an easy bucket before he hit his
three. And um, I don't know, I
don't know shit about anything,
but if I was a scout I would pay attention
to that just as much as somebody's
actually doing great things out on the
court. And, um, it was insane, dude.
Fucking coach k coming out. I,
I just, I'm reminded me when I,
when I went to the kings game,
when they wrapped it up one time to win
a Stanley Cup and I saw them bring the
Stanley Cup out. It was like that
except it could walk around talking.
So I want to thank, uh,
I want to thank my call at the comedy
zone in Charlotte for two awesome shows
and thank you so much for, uh,
getting us in touch with the person
that hooked us up with the tickets. Uh,
may verzion Barnick we're all sitting
there going, I think that might've been
okay.
The greatest sporting event I went to,
obviously seeing the Patriots win
the super bowl was bigger, but um,
the level of excitement,
like I, I just never been,
never been to anything like that. And
uh, if you ever get a fucking chance, um,
that is definitely one worth stub. Hubbing
um,
oh,
the college give fucking the students
were crazy and they had all these funny
chance and I'm sure everybody's going
to say all they stole this from you.
They stole this from this guy
and blah, blah blah blah blah.
I don't fucking know. But it
was making me laugh, you know,
when they were introduced in the
UNC players, I'll just use my name.
They just say,
Ya play in fucking that point guy
number fucking zero bill burn.
And then the whole student section
just goes, hi bill, you suck.
And they just did it to the
whole thing. It was childish.
It was fucking hilarious.
They started chanting,
I couldn't tell what they were chanting
and then gradually figured it out.
It was crazy towel guy. I was like, crazy,
what the fuck are they saying? Crazy?
What? And people start turning around
looking at us, and then I realized,
I look and be honest.
So we look up and all of a sudden
this fucking old guy gets up,
starts whipping this towel around his
head, this old fucking lunatic. I'm like,
oh, I guess that's like I
said, some crazy towel guy.
Right?
So it's gone back and
forth, back and forth,
all these crazy chance you let your
whole team down all of this shit.
The next thing you know, it's like
halftime. We're sitting there going like,
dude, what the fuck was that?
That was 20 minutes of basketball.
That felt like a minute.
My ears were ringing.
Like I'd gone to a concert and
there's still another half to play.
Then all of a sudden this Asian lady comes
out this Asian way coming out on like
a fucking three story unicycle,
and she's doing that act where you,
you're fucking, you flip
the saucer Rania head. Okay.
Which I had seen before. I've seen the
act done before. I've never seen it live,
but it fucking hilarious. Versie
barnick had never seen that.
That's saying I wasn't blown away.
I was definitely blown away. So she,
she goes to f like flip it on
her head and the first of all,
you know when you stop on a
Unicycle, you can't just stop.
You gotta do that front, back,
front, back, front, back to it.
Now she's doing that with one
foot on the fucking pedal.
She's got a goddamn
soup bowl on one of our,
the end of her feet on a toes. Your feet.
A lot of people know it as your toes,
right? So everybody's sitting
there, right? She fucking flips it.
It does like a triple Lindy and lands
on the top of her head and everybody's
just like, oh shit. Right?
So then she fucking,
what the thing still on her fucking head,
the little soup kitchen. A Cup dare,
right. She rides down to another, the
other corner of the basketball court.
Now she puts two down now for as he
starts going, no way. No fucking way.
No fuck away air right there,
Fred. It fucking lands. Oh crowd.
Oh Shit. Then she goes to do three.
So she's got one upright,
the other's upside down.
The others upright just going like right
up her fucking Shin and she fucking
landed that and first z stood up.
You have to see what black people go to
church and whether they call it catching
the holy ghost. That's what looked
like happened to Paul versus
everybody was sitting down
for, he stood up and applauded.
I'm fucking dying laughing. She goes
to four balls. Everybody's like,
no shit. Four balls go in the
air. Land right on her head. One,
two, three, four hole
crap. What the fuck? Right?
Then she goes down, her
closing bit, not one,
not two, not three or four.
She puts five fucking soup bowls.
It's all the way up to her knee.
Okay. Oh, I forgot to tell you this.
This guy's like flipping the bowls.
So he flipped one tour and
he fucking threw a two short.
She dropped it and I was going,
I fuck he just jinxed her.
He just fucked with their rhythm.
It's like calling a time
out to ice the kicker.
So she's got five flips them up in the
fucking air. One, two, three, four,
and the fifth one bounced off
my head. Everybody's like, ah,
ah Geez. There is no Santa Claus, right?
You know what she said? She said,
fuck that. Set him up again. Right?
Teaching these kids,
these fucking millennials or whatever
the fuck you call these kids nowadays,
these kids who grew up with knee
pads, elbow pads and helmets,
when they rode bicycles,
they had play dates.
They weren't left alone in the company
of adults that no one really knew who
they were. These, these
kids were sheltered.
They don't know how to make a comeback.
These kids get drunk. They Call Uber,
right? Everything's just set up for them.
So they don't know how to fucking pull
themselves off the mat, you know? Well,
let me tell you something. This lady
on this one fucking tired bicycle,
she showed them how cause
she said, hey, fuck it.
I don't give a shit that you throw me
five more. She sent him up again, right?
Flip them in the air. Landed all
five fucking place goes nuts.
Just as loud as the God damn.
Almost as loud as the fucking game.
There was no break, there was no break
in the excitement that fucking ends.
We're looking going, what the
fuck did we just see and outcomes,
coach k fucking Duke and
UNC and it gets loud again.
More chanting, more singing, more
fucking screaming came all the way down.
Duke finally put the game away with like
a fucking minute left with a couple of
foul shots. And uh,
I just sat there in the last few seconds
when I knew that Tuk was going to win
and I just looked at, looked around,
looked at everything I could look at,
try to make enough mental
pictures as I could to take it in.
Cause I knew I was just like,
I don't know if I'll ever get back
to seeing one of these again. But um,
I dunno if that didn't sell you,
I'd fucking, you gotta do it.
That is a two fuck Madison
Square Garden. It's a mecca.
Fuck that place. You can go down
there and see the fucking ice.
Capades save your money.
Go on stubhub. All right,
go on stuff up and just get
yourself some tickets and go there.
You will not be disappointed. And you
gotta go while coachK is still there.
Who by the way,
I believe tomorrow the
13th is his 70th birthday.
Okay.
How great does that guy look?
Fucking guy looks like he's like maybe
a year younger, two years older than me.
I don't know. Um, who would've thought
without, with uh, a job that's stressful.
You could still look that
good, you know? Um, anyways,
let me read a little bit of advertising.
Here we go. All right. Dollar
Shave Club. Everybody. Dollar Shave
Club. All right. You know something,
there's no reason to use cheap
disposable rate to use it.
A cheap disposable razor or pay a
ridiculously high price for some gimmicky
thing that's got a laser
pointer with 17 blades.
Make this choice and join dollar
shave club before dollar shave club.
It was either save money and get
a painful shape from a disposable,
like the ones that give
away for free at the gym,
which felt like shaving with
the piece of fucking glass.
Or you paid a fortune for
the latest gimmicky shave
breakthrough that you didn't
need that had like a fucking laser cin
detector or 17 blades or whatever dollar
shave club is the best of both worlds.
Worlds a premium shade
at a disposable price.
Get it clothes, smooth shave
every time. And uh, you can't,
you can't beat the convenience or the
price of the club if you haven't tried
dollar shave club yet, you're missing
out. It's an amazing shape. God,
they write so much fucking
copy. There's no smarter choice.
And right now they're giving away
a, what am I try for? Only a,
any that raises for only a dollar.
It's free shipping after that,
it's just a few bucks a month. There's
no long term commitment, no hidden fees.
You can cancel whatever the fuck you want.
Get your $1 trial@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burn that's dollar shave
club.com/bar oh in some of our
faith. One of my favorites here.
Look who's back. It's all zip.
Are you hiring?
Why do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
You sent them a bitch.
Posting your jobs in one place isn't
enough to find high quality candidates.
You might as well walk down the
street and say, hey buddy, buddy,
do you want a job? No jogging. Sorry.
Right. You might as well do it that way.
That make any sense? Probably
didn't. I'm just saying, you know,
p p people use this shit. You're
going to be behind the eight ball.
This is why I stick to the copy posts
of your job and once one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the
top job sites and now you can with zip.
Yeah,
rhoda.com you can post your job to 200
plus job sites including social media
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find the candidates in any
city or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use. Interface. No juggling
emails or calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates, rate
them. Ah, look at her tits.
We'll give her a shot and hire the right
person fast. Find out today why zip
has been used by fortune 100 companies
and thousands of small and medium sized
businesses right now.
My listeners can post a job on
ZipRecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/birth and zip
recruiter.com/bar one more time.
Try It for free and go to zip.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] dot com slash Berg MVMT
watches, also known as movement watches.
Pronounced movement was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank.
With the 1 million watches
sold to customers in 160
countries around the fucking
world.
Movement watches has solidified itself
as one of the fastest growing watches
companies. And let me tell you,
the owners of this company will,
they're personalize, have suffered
broken marriages, broken dreams,
but God damn it, they get into
these fucking watches. Um,
the company started by two broke college
kids. They didn't have any money.
And then somehow they started a company.
I've never understood that detail.
A wanting to wear stylish watches,
but they couldn't afford it,
so they started their own watch company.
This definitely sounds like
an ivy league thing. You know,
when I didn't have a fucking
watch and I didn't have any money,
I just didn't wear a watch. I didn't
start a fucking watch company.
These Kennedys, I was, okay,
how is this like how you started
build a five shut up movement.
Watches start at just $95 a department
store at a department store,
you're looking at four to 500
bucks. Move in watches. Okay.
Basically they got a great watch.
It's not in a department store so they
can cut out all this fucking money.
You know, they start at 95 bucks.
The great people won't know that
there's a piece of shit. You know?
It's not a piece of shit, but they won't
know that. It's not like a fucking,
you know, how do we get out of
this? It's a nice watch. All right,
but it doesn't cost a lot of money. Okay.
Over 1 million watches
sold in over 160 countries.
Get 50% off today with free shipping
with free returns by going to movement
watches.com/berg this watch has a really
clean design. Seriously. All right.
You'll get a bunch of compliments
whenever you put it on. Okay.
Even if it's sitting on,
oh my God. Is that a,
that's a really nice quality
watch. Don't touch it.
Now's the time to step up.
Big Game. Go to a movement,
watches.com/burb join the movement.
Oh mercifully, this is the last one.
Oh, stamps.com and everybody, you know,
I use stamps.com whenever I send out
my posters of my, uh, my sports bras,
whatever the fuck I'm selling at the end
of shows to whore myself out. You know,
when I was like, you know what, I,
I'm going to go out here and make a
little bit of extra cash, you know,
shake some hands whenever he 15 is going
to fucking feel like they just got out
of a sauna. Postage rates
have gone up. Again,
that means trips to the post up post
office or even an even bigger hassle. Man,
it's so crowded,
but thanks to stamps.com you
don't have to worry about that.
Just use stamps.com to automatically
calculate and print the correct amount of
postage for every letter or packages.
Send stamps.com brings you all this
service to the post office right to your
fingertips. We'll even
send you a digital scale.
Automatically calculate the
exact post as they do everything,
but send a fucking robot
and then to do it for you.
stamps.com we'll even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs. They give you postage discounts.
You can't get into the post office
including 3 cents off every first class
stamp. Right now, use my code
borough for this special offer.
Four week trial includes
post agenda digital scale.
Why would the post office student 3 cents
off going into their business? They,
they must have a cut of
stamps.com I have no idea.
Four week trial includes
a postage includes postage
and a digital stale scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone,
whatsapp the homepage and type in birth
that stamps.com enter Uber and sign up
today with stamps.com you'll never have
to go to the God damn post office again.
All right, and with that, you know this,
this thing is just really not
responding the way it used to.
Is it time for a new laptop? All right.
Do we have anything else? Hey, what is
all this attacking on fake news lately?
I don't understand it. Why is the
government getting so mad at fake news?
It's so fucking hilarious watching them
getting up and getting upset about that.
Hey, don't read their fake
news. Read our fake news.
Read our version of the fucking,
it's all fake fucking news.
Have you ever gotten into a car accident?
Little fender bender and the cop
shows up? Are you a police officer?
Have you ever heard two people
tell you the exact same story?
This fucking guy came out of fucking
nowhere. Then you go over the other guy.
What happened? I came out of fucking
nowhere. I wasn't even looking.
Never happens. It's all fake
news. It's all opinions,
right?
[inaudible]
for the most part, other than,
you know, if somebody dies,
this guy is fucking dead. Okay.
You can agree on that. How we died,
why he died, who's, who's responsible?
Oh, Jesus Christ. But we get it. Okay.
That's all I'm saying. That's all. That's
all I'm really saying here. All right,
let's get to, well, let's get to the
content here. Um, you read some, uh,
some of your letters here. Alright.
Yoko Ono makes Julian Lennon by
letters he wrote to his dad at auction.
All right, Bill, is there a worst
woman in history? I hate to be hacky.
I know the Beatles days were numbered.
It wasn't just her, but it didn't help.
Yeah. But at the end of the day,
John Shows her, Jesse, what happened?
Something happened between John and
his mom and she died or she fucking,
I dunno, she beat him with a wooden spoon.
I forget how the fucking story went.
All right. But whatever she did or
if she died, it's not her fault.
It left him with the psychological
makeup to be susceptible to not trying to
just find a mate.
He also wanted a mom and all she
had to do was make some cookies.
All right,
make him some cookies on his fucking
birthday, whatever the fuck he wanted,
and then that was it. This guy was
done. You know, I think he wouldn't,
you know,
if he lived the somewhere in his mid
forties he just would've been like,
all right. You know what? What the fuck
was that? Maybe you would've got up.
Maybe. Maybe he liked it. I have no idea.
But anyways, let's continue. He said,
then there's the video.
Will you call her out for screeching
like a maniac during a powerful moment of
history.
Now she won't give her husband's son
some paper he gave his dad 20 years
earlier. This story might be a bit
old, but it doesn't seem to make,
but it doesn't make it any less
true. I watched the clip. What it is,
was she auctioned off a bunch
of his shit is what it is.
She's not making him pay for it. She
sold it. And Julian wants to get it back,
but because Yoko sold it, um,
he has to buy it back.
Now I'm in defense for what I
would say is the cash cow died.
It's not like Yoko could go
out and fucking cell, take
a records like a beetle.
So all of a sudden she's
gone like, Holy Fuck,
how am I still going to be able
to live in the, in the Dakota?
So she selling all this shit
or maybe her husband died.
She wanted to fucking move on and
didn't want to look at all his old shit.
You know what I mean? I
have no idea. Um, but yeah,
I watched a little, that video. Julianne
definitely goes hard on her and says,
uh, that you think, see, she's
extremely manipulative and that, um,
she knew what the fuck she
was doing from day one.
And I can't remember if that's
actually his mother. I Dunno.
How was he related? It you, who
the fuck knows? I don't know. Um,
okay.
Is there a worse woman in history?
Yeah, there's way worse women,
those women that ran empires
and had people killed, you know,
for whatever fucking reason. You
know, the, the, the story of Scarface,
the second one, the one
that Pachino did was based
on a, a, you know, there
was the original movie,
but the stories that they
used in, in the second one,
uh,
were based on a drug dealer of
that time who actually was a woman.
So I mean, yeah, I would
say she was worse. You know,
having people shot in the fucking street
is probably worse than a sell on some
postcards, but, you know, it's all
up to interpretation. You know,
this is the new me, the
new meditating bill,
the mood more relaxed bill who's undoing
the fucking nuts of anxiety in his
mind. I cannot say enough
about fucking meditating.
Um,
now that I'm not trying to like get
good at it, I'm just trying to do it.
Um,
I don't flip out to the level I
used to like, I think, you know,
say like 10 is the worst flipping
out. I think I used to walk around,
just walk around on a good day.
I was already at a six compared to how
most people are when they're just like
totally chilling out.
So it was a very quick and
easy trip up to 10. Uh,
now I feel like I walk around at like a
three. I feel like I've cut it in half.
So now when I flip out
I kinda just go to six,
which is still totally unacceptable
for most social situations.
I still flip out and people look over
their shoulders startled but not with the
level of, of what the
fuck, you know what I mean?
Reminds you this time I saw
I was on like highway eight
or something interstate eight,
I think I was in Arizona, New Mexico.
I don't where the fuck I was
at and this bull, it somehow
gotten free. I mean I was in
the middle of fucking nowhere.
I was and there was two cowboys right
on horses and these are cowboys.
They're trying to fucking
rope a Goddamn bull,
which I didn't know if you can do. I
don't what the fuck they were doing.
So one of them is trying to distract
the bull is the other one is on a horse
that is sneaking up behind it.
And the course is sneaking up the way
horses sneak up in a fucking cartoon.
And this bowl at the last second figured
it out and he fucking turned around.
You know that look,
Bruce Willis always does when he
looks over his shoulder and die hard.
It's the same thing except it was a
fucking bull. That's the look that people,
when I would lose my shit prior to
meditating, I would get that look.
Everyone would fucking turn
around. Like, you know,
a skyscraper was on fire and it was just
some fucking balding redhead flipping
out because he couldn't figure out
the new operating system on his,
on his smart phone.
Okay.
Completely unacceptable.
So, uh, my temper is,
has really reduced and, um,
I'm telling you, if I
could just not fucking do,
I just made this statement
out loud. It's like, I'm,
my daughter's not going to
see me flipping out, you know,
I'm not saying I want it every way.
Hey, hey, hey, hey. Hey, hey. Would,
she's fucking drawn on the
wall at some point, but, uh,
she's not going to see me yelling at
computers. It's just not going to happen.
Okay. And I say it out loud. When I
say it out loud, that means it happens.
Right? I hope so many ways. I'm
trying. Fuck you guys. I'm trying.
Anytime I talk about this
too in my standup back,
then I'm going to try to fix my
temper. People just start laughing.
They laugh when they point and
they make me feel bad. I'm alright.
Italy and the European Union.
Hey, their Capitol Hill Bill.
I'm just a bill. Yes.
I'm only a bill and I'm sitting
here on Capitol Hill and okay.
I'm a political science professor from
a school I won't name to keep with your
policy of not naming names a having
studied and taught the subject.
It's fair to say I look at what goes
on today from a much wider scope.
A wider scope than who? Me. I would
hope so. I would hope so wider than me.
Um, all right.
And that's not something that is only
exclusive to receiving a master's in
political science. Could you pat
yourself on the back any more? Sir?
Did you elbow patch?
Fly off your fucking left arm of your
sport coat when you reach back to that is
all,
I love this guy and that's not all these
something that is only exclusive to
receiving a master's in political science.
This guy should be wearing a scarf with
a nice breeze going. Anyone can read
souls in each sin.
Thank you for fucking sound spelling
that for me and others who have honestly
captured an important perspective
of history and have a much clearer
understanding of how and why governments
and socialites have evolved through
history. Anyways,
there is one thing that has flown under
the radar now that I've gotten my resume
out of the way.
There's one thing that has flown under
the radar and I think it should scare the
shit out of most European
countries. All right.
Let me start by saying in short
that the European Union parentheses,
which in my opinion is run
by fascist self interest,
can I just stop here and say this is
the most well-written fucking email I've
ever received on the podcast.
Okay.
This is incredible. Um, let me start by
saying in short to the European Union,
which my opinion is run by
fascist with self interest,
tried to take control of Italy's
army for the sake of your time.
I will spoil the ending.
Italy did not vote to allow the EU
to take over that move by the EU.
Alarmed some of my peers who I in 20
plus years of knowing them have not seen
them alarmed by anything in terms of
government, in the scheme of things,
a banking institution,
openly financing legislation that is
trying to gain control of a foreign
countries, foreign governments. Military
is for the lack of a better term,
really, really ballsy. Why do I feel
like I missed some information here?
Okay, so the, the European Union
tried to take over Italy's army. Okay.
I see that Italy did not vote
to allow the EU to take over.
So when you joined the European Union,
they took take over your army,
is that what you're saying? Okay,
so that moved by the EU
alarm. Some of my peers.
What move? Oh, trying
to take over the, okay,
but you're jumping back and forth here.
I can't tell what you're talking about.
Can take control of Italy's army case.
So them trying to take control of their
army. Yeah. How would you do that?
Okay. The idea that,
let me just finish this,
the idea that certain globalist groups
are trying to take control of the world
is not an incredible idea among people
who are versed in political economics or
conspiracy theorists like myself.
But you know something
me, they just go, oh,
where do you get your
fucking 10 hat on? And a you,
if you just started saying
what the fuck you just said,
you'd probably run into the
same problem like you just,
I just said it was the best written
email ever and I got lost in it cause I'm
too fucking stupid. I understand
what you're talking about.
So it's gotta be hard, man.
You just got to hang out with people
with the fucking elbow patches on their
sport coats. Right. Anyways.
The idea that certain globalist groups
are trying to take control of the world
is not an incredible idea among people
who are versed in political economics.
I have heard you talk about stuff like
this in the context of a conspiracy and
so other than this possibly possibly
being interesting to you. It's also too,
it's also affirm that you
are not out of your mind.
I attached an article if
you'd like to read further,
absolutely would look at this. How about
that? Everybody all you can't stand.
I got a 10 hat on tinfoil hat
on. Whatever the fuck that means.
Half of you say that you
don't even know what it means.
You get your tinfoil
tinfoil add on. You know,
I don't even know what the fuck it
means. Is that, is that like my antenna?
If I'm doing some sort of pirate radio,
tin foil hat meaning I know what it means.
Weed you out of your fucking
mind, but how did it come about?
The tinfoil hat is made from one
or more sheets of aluminum foil.
I didn't want the exact or a piece of
conventional head gear lined with foil
worn in the belief or hope that it
shields the brain from threats such as
electromagnetic fields, mind
control in mind. Right. Oh, I see.
I see. Well, you know,
that's a macgyver shit.
I can go with that. Right. Set
a bad thing. Anyways. Well,
where the fuck was I?
Um,
I've attached a, I wouldn't, I would
actually to relate to how long is this?
So is this something I can read? You know,
I'll read about this and I'll
give you my uninformed opinion,
my moronic opinion on the next podcast.
How about that? Does that work for you?
Does that grab you? I'm all right.
Fat guys turns out to not be fat.
Billy twinkle Bowes. Um, this guy told,
was told by a doctor his
whole life that he was fat.
He had this huge frontal thing on going
on that turned out to not be a giant
belly, but 130 pound tumor.
How many people do you know will
start using the tumor defense?
MMM [inaudible]
I actually looked this fucking thing
up. The guy is fat. He's very fat.
Even after the fucking tumor.
I mean like he's laying in bed,
any has, it's like he is an inner
tube of fat going around the like,
that's what his neck is.
This guy is so fucking fat.
He had a 130 pound tumor and he just
thought it was part of his love handle.
He is fat. Um, I'm glad they got
it out of there. Geez. How do you,
I didn't get that out of
their hundred and 30 pounds.
How the fuck do you, I mean, you
gotta take it out in sections
10 pounds at a time. You need
to make 13 fucking incisions,
Jesus Christ and just thrown
it over your shoulder,
hitting the ground like
a fucking bowling ball.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ. Do you know, I knew a guy
dead. Um,
you know,
everybody's talking about probiotics
and they talk about the bacteria in your
gut that it will, you know,
there's bacteria in your gut
that's supposed to be there.
They try to scare the shit out of
you, but it's supposed to be there.
It's there for when you die in a begins
to did decomposing process provided
you're not full of fucking preservatives
and you just decompose because you not
important and you just become
part of the earth again.
But we stick ups ourselves in these fancy
fucking boxes because we think we're
too good to be warm food for whatever
fucking reason. But anyways, um,
alcohol,
okay,
eats away at the good shit, the good
bacteria that you need while you're alive.
Like you supposed to be balanced and
you're supposed to have more of the good
bacteria cause you have
more of the bad bacteria,
you can actually enter
your own fucking way.
You beginning to decompose while you're
still alive or in a short way you
starting to die. This is the
way this guy explained it to me.
So he started getting a distended belly.
They didn't know what the fuck was going
on and he wouldn't go to the doctor.
And then finally you found out, you know,
somebody said maybe you got a tape worn
and that freaked them the fuck out.
They could've been something alive in him.
And he went to the doctor and then
they found out that that's what it was.
And uh, they gave him some
medicine and you know,
Eddie had to shit it all out. That's
basically what happens. So, um,
I don't know. Even then I always buy
the Greek yogurt and it goes bad.
I always think like,
and I'll slam a couple of scotches and
the next morning I have two spoonfuls of
fucking Greek yogurt yoga and I'll be
fine. I was happy in the life insurance,
they said on a nice fucking
easy, you know, heart rhythm.
I was also meditating when they did it.
You know, I was being totally present.
I was listening to the sounds of
the room. I slowed my breathing,
I tricked those fuckers. But I also had
the Bruins game on in the background.
So I was trying not to react
to what the fuck was going on.
Cause we'd left his fucking cunty goal
at the end of the second period with like
one second left. All
right. Crazy. Sadam story.
Crazy. Alright. Hey,
bill thought I brighten your day with
this crazy account of what went down in
Iraq. When Sadam took power,
basically the gathered all
government officials in one room,
the current military leader gets
brought out on stage. He clearly,
he's clearly been beaten. He
admits to having committed treason,
but clearly he hasn't. They then start
calling out officials one at a time,
so everyone was scared
shitless that they'd be called
out and marched out into a
courtyard with the others. Then
after half of them were gone,
the remaining officials were all taken
out to the courtyard and told that if
they didn't shoot the traders,
they and their families would be killed.
That way they all had blood
on their hands. Insane.
Here's the whole account and did think
that u s still did business with Saddam,
with them after that. Ha
Ha Dude. As far as I know,
we kind of put that guy in over there,
you know
it,
and we were cool with the guy until he
fucking tried to go around us and start
selling oil. The other, I don't know
what the fuck he did. We, you know,
you know what I mean? Saddam
was saying to the United States,
he was like one of those fucking a first
round draft choices that that's a bust.
He was a bust for us, you know, in
a very promising college career.
And you know, he just, he just
didn't have the passion. Actually.
He was a very passionate guy. He
just wasn't passionate in the wrong,
I don't know who the fuck knows.
I mean it's all evil shit.
That shit is just like,
um,
it's the most base level evil cause
they're not even trying to hide it.
But I got to tell you, when Trump
was talking to that fucking guy,
they're on from Fox News,
Bill O'Reilly and Bill O'Reilly's
giving him shit that he was friends with
Putin, Putin or whatever the
fuck his name is. And he goes,
the guys that he's a killer to have
a fucking standing president go,
well look at this country. Look
what we'll look what we've done.
My jaw hit the fucking ground. Like,
is he actually going to say this?
You can't say this.
Everybody knows it's true.
But you can't fucking say this now.
We only kill the bad
people. The Fuck Outta here.
It's all fucking evil. And that
goes back to that fake news.
That's why they need to take control
of the fake news so they can spin it.
You know what I mean? The Guy,
he came out of fucking nowhere.
The sedan was saying, where
are we at? A green light.
He came out of fucking nowhere.
Everybody does it. Everybody does it.
You know what? And I fucking do
it too. We're all spinning it.
We're all spinning our own horse
shit. We all think we're Fike.
I'm not going to speak for you guys,
but I'm spinning my own bullshit, right?
This is my favorite video anybody's
sent me in a long fucking time now. Oh,
by the way, if you want to watch
that sit down thing, uh, I'll,
I'll post all these videos. I don't
know if I want to watch it. That stuff.
I Dunno. I don't like
watching shit like that.
Um,
all right. 109 year old guy
smoked cigars and drinks whiskey.
Dear Billy F deer farm state bill. I know
you have a life insurance policy test,
but I thought you might want to see this.
This 109 year old guy smoked cigars all
day. Not Saying it's great for everyone,
but figured you'd want to hear the title.
Actually marginalize this guy's life.
He's got a great
attitude. He still drives.
He's the oldest living World War II
veteran. You'd really enjoy this.
He talks about having a truck for a long
time and they show his old school TV
with the giant dials. He keeps it
all because it works and he likes it.
Come to Boston. I fucking love this guy.
He said at one point he smokes 12
cigars a day. He goes, I don't inhale.
So you inhale, he goes, you get in
trouble. The bottom line is, you know,
whatever's genetics are, this works for
him. Cause I know if I smoked 12 a day,
I, first of all, I couldn't
physically fucking do it, but he had,
it's like a 79 look like a
78 or 79 Ford pickup truck,
yet an old square TV that still had
the legs on it from like the 70s.
Um,
he built his house in like 1940.
He still lives there. He said,
I like the shit that I have. It still
works so I'm not buying more shit.
It's like what I'm trying to do now,
get rid of all this
extra shit that I bought
and um,
I got to tell you,
watching this guy watching his life is
the life that I'm slowly moving towards.
It's the life that I want.
Um,
after running around
like a fucking lunatic,
reacting to everything for
the first fucking, you know,
40 something years of my life.
Um,
you know, I would like to slow down a
little bit is far as of, I mean, look,
I'm still, I know all you guys are
worried. I got God, he's gonna slow down.
He's not going to be fucking far. I'm
still going to completely fuck up,
still going to do dumb
shit. I'm going to be fine,
but I don't have to be walking
or I basically walked around,
stuck in fight or flight mode probably
from the age of eight till now.
And um, I dunno,
it's just stupid with stats.
It's funny to observe but it really
wears on the people around you and
eventually it fucking wears you down.
And it's just like the amount of fucking
time that I have wasted arguing with
people where they're not
going to change their mind.
I'm not going to change my mind. I've
just, I, I've, uh, I've done, uh,
past that point my fucking life
and it feels fucking great.
I just have to believe that I am.
Um,
I'm trying to do now when I flip up,
cause I know there's other
angry constantly listen
to this and you listen to
this because I'm an angry conduit.
It probably makes you feel
better about yourself.
Um,
which is why I love Bobby Knight bought
you watch Bobby night and you're like,
oh my God, I'm a fucking saint. This guy.
Now this guy has got a temper that
I'm telling you right now. Yeah.
Your wife ever gives you
shit for having a temper.
It's like you think I got a temper,
just cut the yard or you
could be married to that.
And I love Bobby Knight by
the way. Um, so anyways,
uh, I just now like, uh,
I don't know. I try to, in the
moment I just try to fucking like,
this is funny thing that happens.
Like when my daughter, uh,
you don't need your diaper
changed. It's like, you know,
you hear him farting and everything.
So you thinking like, okay,
that's definitely a, you
know, when you, you, I mean,
without getting into the gross details,
just think you here the farm and you
think that's the gun sounding the end of
the game. And then when she get into it,
you realize that wasn't the gun sounding
the end of the game or even the end of
the half. That was the sound of the
fucking jets flying over the game,
over the stadium right after
the fucking national anthem.
And the game's about ready to begin.
Um,
I left pad save yesterday,
block cheese block,
saved my wall, took it all on my
shirt and all that. It's just like,
okay,
it's fucking unbelievable.
And whenever that happens,
like a couple of times I went like,
Nia, she, why'd you tell me to come in?
And she's still going.
Like she could tell like there's any way
for my wife to know whether my daughter
is done going to the bathroom or
not. She's got no fucking idea.
And I just, I apologized, eh, uh,
I just addressed that I was angry and I,
and I did it two more fucking
times and now, now I got it down.
Now he just say something as I walk up
to the changing table at three or four in
the morning. And I just basically
say, if she's not done, and you know,
this is not anybody's fault, this is
just part of having a kid don't flip out.
And I, and I'll see how that works for
me tonight. That's just based. I just,
before I just kept it all in my
head and then it becomes like,
it isn't that it's Sorta,
sorta real but isn't,
I just find when I say it out loud,
then I can fucking address it and uh,
so we'll see that. But uh, I gotta tell
you, I actually fucking really enjoy,
uh, changing diapers and everything.
We gave my daughter her first bath
ever right in the kitchen sink,
old school style.
I'm sure we were supposed to have like
a fucking hazmat suit team come in and
disinfect the sink and she's supposed
to wear a helmet and some scuba gear,
but uh, that's not our bringing her up.
We'll go and we'll go on old school.
I've been playing music
for, on everything.
Got this exercise ball and really just
kind of puts you to sleep and I just play
music and she just totally chills out.
Um,
the stuff that she's enjoyed so far,
she's, she likes Herbie Hancock.
I was playing some Billy carbons, some
of this shit I just been listening to.
Um,
what else has she been listed? Some
of the pop stuff she really likes.
I think they just liked music in general.
They just kind of like, what the,
what is that? And uh, I dunno,
it's getting to that point.
She's just starting to be able to look
around and you kind of sit there going
like,
I think she's actually looking at me
right now then right as you make a guy
contact, like, hey,
are you fucking looking at me or I just
kind of drift away and look at something
else. I'm like, Eh, I guess I'm still
like an acid trip when she looks at me.
Um,
but anyways, we're having
a great time and I,
even though I'm not getting any sleep,
um, it's totally fucking worth it.
And uh, it's, it's, I'll tell you
if funeral, if you're an older dad,
it's not as fucking hard.
They tried to say, oh my God,
you're old and going to try
to do this. It's like, yeah,
I'm old and I have a house. You know,
I'm not some fucking struggling 20
something, you know what I mean?
Fucking broke kid trying to pay off
student loans. And then you have a kid,
people in their twenties, if they
complain about having a kid, I, I, yeah,
without a doubt. I'll listen to that.
But if you're in your thirties and
forties, ain't could go fuck yourself.
All right. That's it. Okay. That's the
podcast for, uh, for Monday. Once again,
please check out Nick DiPaolo special, um,
on CSO this Thursday at
8:00 PM. I'm telling you,
he's one of the best of his generation
and one of the best of the last fucking
whatever, whatever the fuck he started
30 years ago, uh, one of my favorites,
and it's a, it's an honor to be
able to plug his special. All right,
so check it out. Your cuts. I'll
check in on you on Thursday.